we're doing the installation broken cage
situations in which the growth of a
population of masses of people all that
kind of thing is proportional to you
however much stuff you've got so that's
why you have when you've had a look at
the evidence
everybody likes a trade the number of
Eminem's that will end up with you shake
them would be less hard side up it's
proportional to however many evidence
you have does that make sense more
in-depth evidence means it's going to
grow faster whatever to happen but
there's multiple different ways to
describe how fast is it growing or a
question cake everything that I'm about
to say he also tries to decay you're
just gonna have some minus signs in a
few spots so the first thing you talk
about is this mysterious phrase which
comes up a few times which is called the
growth rate and that's that's all it's
called right you like what does that
refer to it could just as easily give
you some words if they want you to
calculate any of the things what we just
when they say just straight strangely
enough all they mean is in a situation
like this B equals 18 all they'd
actually be please just
hey yeah whatever I put this in this
particular spot okay it's proportional
so what this means is it doesn't matter
what a is doesn't matter a is your goose
tiny five thousand bacteria population
write this value K is completely
independent to what that a is okay so
it's not an absolute than that look like
on day three hundred new bacteria in my
bloodstream every moment which is good
point you show you necessarily back me
and also three hundred is a really small
number becomes bacteria right
this over here is independent of that so
it's a it's a proportional
okay because it's this constant that
appears we often also called me be
constant all proportionality and
sometimes that would just outright say
please find they're close to the focal
point melody won't find okay will find
the correct rate okay why do you agree
there go instantaneous yeah we talked
about it being proportional uh we're
also in this topic of exponential growth
and decay and this is upset on calculus
right yes so when we think about how
fast something is growing since we have
access to calculus we can actually work
out at what instant in time what is the
growth rate line right there would be
sort of equivalent to in here what the
tangent is okay so at a particular
instant like right now it's growing in
Israel
okay that's how I work that out right
now in this situation here hump RP
equals that if I want to do it well how
they three hundred that's true the per
second three million bacteria per second
I'm in some serious trouble okay what I
would need I want to be instantaneous
rate at a particular point in time I
need the derivative don't actually need
to know DP on duty in this case or I'm
gonna put P - I'm gonna say at a
particular point in time like same time
one let's just give it a name hey when
time one is a given point in time and
that can be any time like it could be at
time zero what's your initial growth of
right it could be off to five hours you
know am I still gonna be live off to
that time t1 can be anybody you like I
just want me in T to remind you that
it's a time that you think is how long
is this situation
okay and again what you're putting it in
to see what it being substituted into
the derivative it's added a single
incident time right so that's why we
called the instantaneous growth
[Applause]